ante estos cinco años atravesamos la
pandemia
retornó la guerra nuestro continente
crisis energética regresó la inflación y
Durante este cinco años el Reino Unido
salió de la Unión Europea en Sanders en
el 2018 recordaba que hay dos cosas
importantes para que un nuevo voto y una
decisión política y que haya esta
pandemia hay que superarla tenemos
nuestra geografía importantísima y
estamos juntos frente a un destino común
el cual Es evidente hoy día tenemos una
historia que nos liga valores
tenemos una amistad
que a veces tiene paréntesis de pronto
en un terreno de fútbol o de rugby sin
ir más lejos en las menciones deportivas
respecto de lo que viene más adelante
y Tenemos
muchos esta geografía nos liga por eso
esta Cumbre es excepcional se trata de
un momento
de reencuentro un momento de reconexión
una nueva partida marca una voluntad
común de coordinarnos mejor construir
nuevas perspectivas en este contexto
creo que la voluntad que usted expresó
de lo que tenemos juntos de lo que
hablamos de nuestros gobiernos de lo que
hemos trabajado y lo que hemos logrado
crear el encuentro
empresariales y los jóvenes líderes van
en el sentido voluntad común que se nos
ha impuesto como algo evidente y esto en
un nuevo contexto internacional que es
el que tenemos ahora en el que Europa en
el sentido geográfico del termo término
Está frente a Nueva responsabilidades
miembros
del Consejo de la de seguridad en
Naciones Unidas fundadores de otan
fuertes convergencias queremos trabajar
juntos y queremos construir soluciones
concretas para el futuro
en este contexto quisiera Mostrar cuán
contentos son estoy de este nuevo viaje
que hemos tomado de comprometerse con la
Unión Europea y felicitarlo en el marco
de Windsor firmado y celebrado con la
presidenta esta nueva partida la vamos a
seguir vamos a seguir adelante y vamos a
aprovechar de ella para también Mostrar
el apoyo a Ucrania compartimos el mismo
análisis la misma voluntad Rusia no
puede y no debe ganar esta guerra desde
el primer día hemos venido apoyando ya
al pueblo de Ucrania en el plano
humanitario militar económico y hacemos
todo para que esta guerra nos extienda y
no se globalice al respecto hemos
acciones concretas en la formación de
militares ucranianos y queremos también
juntos preparar las próximas semanas y
en los próximos meses con una convicción
comunes algo Hay que encontrar una
salida a este conflicto y necesitamos
que Ucrania está en la mejor posición
posible para que logre los términos de
una negociación entonces en la manera de
realizar las operaciones hoy día se
trata construir una paz duradera y
aceptable que acepte el derecho
internacional y los intereses del pueblo
ucraniano hace un año día hace
justamente había un consejo importante
en donde se definía la autonomía
estratégica durante ese momento
afirmabamos que Ucrania pertenecía a la
familia europea es autonomía estratégica
también se ha construido mediante una
relación fuerte Algo que queremos
también construir con su país por en
materia de seguridad y de defensa
hemos debatido ampliamente de la manera
de reforzar Más allá del conflicto de la
agresión rusa y el conflicto que hay
reforzar nuestras capacidades comunes
trabajar
la interoperabilidad técnica humana Y
estoy pensando específicamente la
voluntad de avanzar en un calendario que
tiene que ver con los misiles antinavíos
y misiles de crucero interoperabilidad
de nuestros sistemas aero respectivos y
también avanzar en Campos tan diversos
como manejo de los fondos marinos y
energía este refuerzo de capacidades es
esencial fundamental y también es lo que
queremos construir para pensar también
los términos de la seguridad Europea de
mañana Es decir tener un verdadero marco
jurídico y verdaderas capacidades para
nuestra protección antimisiles y
construir lo que va a suceder después de
que se tomen estas decisiones del nuevo
recomienzo queremos trabajar ahora en
aras de nuestro continente para
desarrollar una estrategia común
reforzar nuestra cooperación y hacerlo
también en Campos claves para nuestros
dos países sitemos unos por ejemplo
cooperación energética en esta materia
la cooperación
no es una cooperación bilateral que
sigue siendo fuerte es fruto de opciones
que han venido de la complementaria de
nuestros dos modelos nuclear lo nuclear
con el y la cooperación Franco británica
sólida en ese sector El proyecto
sayswell que apoyamos plenamente y que
también dará más dinamismo económico y
la voluntad también de seguir adelante
con esta unidad y proyectos comunes en
el campo civil y reforzar también
nuestros proyectos y nuestras
inversiones cru esta mañana mismo vimos
que en materia de energía renovable
ustedes tienen una experticia
capacidades enormes particularmente en
aspectos eólicos y se necesita una
coordinación en el tema del carbono
nuestros intereses son conjuntos también
están los temas ambientales con una
ambición común acelerar la salida de las
energías fósiles pero también reformar
nuestra arquitectura financiera
internacional el apoyo a la lucha contra
el cambio climático particularmente
preparando los resultados de la Cumbre
que se realizará en París el 23 de junio
que tiene que ver con el nuevo pacto
financiero y reforzar nuestros
compromisos comunes en materia de
defensa de la biodiversidad y esto a
través de las diferentes encuentros con
del final del año por ejemplo para
concretar juntos decisiones
lucha contra la inmigración irregular
Aquí también queremos avanzar de común
cada uno tiene conciencia de los
compromisos humanos que hay ahí de la
enorme sensibilidad que tienen estos
temas y estamos ya actuando ya aquí
Quiero agradecer a nuestros ministros y
Al conjunto de los equipos que trabajan
de manera tan estrecha en dos fueron dos
mil trescientas travesías de embarcación
que no pueden hacerse criminalidad
organizada detenida y más de 500
arrestos Se realizaron gracias a la
inteligencia conjunta Franco británica
el 14 de noviembre se realizó un marco
bilateral para seguir adelante la lucha
contra la inmigración irregular hoy día
decidimos continuar en el mismo sentido
y de manera altamente operacional y
concreta conscientes del carácter
compartido de nuestra responsabilidad
a este respecto lo que hemos decidido
justamente es una coordinación reforzada
de nuestras actividades nuevas
iniciativas de ambas partes se trata de
actuar juntos en un marco compartido y
vimos también se trata de poder hacerlo
con el conjunto de los europeos
que también se ven afectados por el
tránsito el paso de inmigrantes y con
algunos países desde donde se organizan
estas travesías Este tráfico tenemos el
grupo de Caleb que al respecto es un
foro pertinente en materia de
coordinación nuestros dos ministros han
trabajado estrechamente y Próximamente
se reunirán sobre el tema pero también
queremos que haya otros países de origen
países implicados en estas redes
clandestinas los pusimos de acuerdo en
la necesidad de aumentar nuestras
capacidades de intervención y de
vigilancia
Igualmente
decidimos reforzar una financiación
plurina anual para que haya mayores
sumas frente a las necesidades esto de
parte y parte de otra parte todos los
aspectos y toda la cooperación de la que
hablamos hoy nos serviría de mayor si no
hubiera acciones concretas para reforzar
Los lazos entre nuestras sociedades
civil hemos
habido
participación y encuentros entre empresa
privada ligados por ejemplo con la
eliminación del carbono buscando y
viendo la complementariedad de lo que
tenemos y avanzar juntos hay talento
Franco británico que ya tiene un
recorrido muy prometedor y que van a ser
los actores de este entendimiento
cordial era indispensable entonces que
ellos también participaran en esta
Cumbre Y en este mismo espíritu nos
hemos comprometido a mayor cooperación
entre nuestros museos nuestra juventud
nuestros deportistas nuestros
establecimientos escolares para
facilitar por ejemplo los viajes
escolares entre los dos países estas son
uno de los temas de esta cumbre número
36 Franco británica y hemos entendido
todos que no es una Cumbre como las
demás y habida cuenta de lo sucedido en
los últimos años y del momento que
atraviesa el planeta y nuestro
continente se trata de una Cumbre con
nuevas ambiciosas y espero
mucha realizaciones concretas aún más
ambiciosas Muchas gracias Primer
Ministro por estar hoy en París
[Aplausos]
Manuel Muchas gracias por recibirnos
aquí hoy
siendo honestos la relación entre
nuestros dos países ha tenido sus
desafíos en los años recientes no me
refiero solamente a Francia sacando a
Inglaterra de la Copa Mundial pero creo
que la reunión de hoy sí significa un
nuevo inicio
una entente renovada estamos mirando
hacia el futuro futuro que se construye
a partir de todo lo que compartimos
nuestra historia nuestra geografía
nuestros valores y un futuro que es
mucho más ambicioso sobre Cómo podemos
trabajar juntos para mejorar las vidas
de las personas a las que servimos hemos
discutido cada aspecto de nuestra
Alianza crucial hoy y hemos tomado
Progreso importante tres áreas en
particular migración ilegal energía y
seguridad
Emmanuel y yo compartimos la misma
creencia las pandillas criminales no
deben poder decidir quién llega a su
país
tras semanas de mi llegada duermo hemos
acordado temas hoy hemos llevado nuestra
cooperación a un nivel sin precedentes
para enfrentar este desafío compartido
estamos anunciando un centro de atención
nuevo en el norte de Francia y un nuevo
centro de comando que reúne a nuestras
fuerzas de seguridad por primera vez
y 500 oficiales más que patrullan las
patrullas las playas francesas
complementados por drones y otras
tecnologías de vigilancia que pueden
ayudar a asegurar nuestro territorio la
legislación de nuestro país
respaldará esto porque la idea es romper
el negocio de las pandillas y remover
Estos factores que hacen que llegue más
personas a la costa del Canal Nosotros
siempre cumplimos con nuestras
obligaciones internacionales pero estoy
convencido de que podemos hacerlo
necesario para resolver ese problema
compartido y detener los botes
el Reino Unido y Francia están
trabajando juntos para que nunca jamás
Putin pueda hacer arma de nuestro
sistema energético usted nos ha ayudado
a asegurar nuestro suministro de energía
nuclear gracias al trabajo del i10
y a través de nuestros puertos si hay
interés
podremos recibir gas no ruso pero hoy
podemos ir más allá incluso
con una nueva alianza energética hemos
firmado un nuevo trato en cooperación
civil y no crear acordamos que Francia
iba a revisar el caso para no
interconexión energética para poder
trabajar junto con nosotros en energía
con bajo producción de carbono queremos
en un futuro en el que cada energía cada
camino de energía que puede alimentar
nuestros hogares venga de fuentes
sostenibles y confiables En tercer lugar
el Reino Unido y Francia comparte en un
lazo especial y una responsabilidad
especial
cuando la seguridad de nuestro
continente es amenazada siempre
estaremos enfrente para defenderlo hoy
vamos incluso más allá para fortalecer
nuestra seguridad y nuestra cooperación
en defensa hemos acordado entrenar
Marines ucranianos ayudarles a dar a
Ucrania una ventaja decisiva en el campo
de batalla y para que Ucrania gane esta
guerra aumentar la interoperabilidad de
nuestras fuerzas asumiendo el potencial
completo de las fuerzas expedición
conjunta para brindar seguridad y
estabilidad en el lindo Pacífico
coordinando nuestros despliegues de
portaaviones y estamos considerando la
exploración de armas complejas como de
largo alcance aéreas
por décadas hemos sido dos de los
mayores poderes defensivos en la tierra
y mayores contribuyentes de otan y
Seguiremos haciéndolo así para defender
la libertad la democracia y el estado de
derecho finalmente hoy también ha habido
una celebración de la riqueza de
nuestras culturas todo lo que nos damos
el uno al otro todo lo que hemos
aprendido el uno del otro hemos acordado
facilitar a nuestros hijos ir al
intercambios escolares
y a los creadores artistas para que
contribuyan juntos y esto me lleva a mi
pensamiento final
con todos los acuerdos que hemos
alcanzado hoy al final
Buscamos que se trate de las personas de
Los lazos familiares de los amistades de
solidaridad que hemos compartido
No hay un ejemplo mayor de esa colección
humana
que la simpatía del pueblo francés
tras el fallecimiento de Su Majestad la
reina y quiero agradecerle a usted
personalmente Emmanuel por la gracia de
sus palabras
dijeron
todo lo que necesitaba saber de usted
como líder y como amigo de Gran Bretaña
aprendido rápidamente en este trabajo
aquí hay cosas que uno puede controlar
hijos que uno no puede controlar y una
cosa que uno no puede controlar es
A quién recibe uno como contraparte
internacional
Siento mucha fortuna de estar sirviendo
al lado suyo y estoy muy emocionado por
el futuro que podemos construir juntos
Muchas gracias amigo mío
[Aplausos]